[Music]
this is the example we left at in the
previous video if we drop a piece of
balsa wood and a metal pin of the same
mass into the water what will happen
will both of them float or will both of
them sink or one stays afloat and one
sinks just by intuition we can say that
the wooden block will float and the
metal pin will sink but if they're of
the same mass why does that happen
shouldn't both float because of the
buoyant force this happens because of
the difference in that density but
what's density look at these two parking
lots of the same size one has three cars
and the other has many cars which one is
more dense this one correct yes now look
at these two forests which one is more
dense with tree theory if this one so in
the same given amount of space if there
are more things we think that if denser
density is simply the measure of how
compact the mass in a substance or
object is if we have to go by a
scientific definition we would say that
it's mass per unit volume in short it
tells us how much mass exists in a given
volume the unit of density is kilogram
per meter cubed mass is in kilograms and
volume in meter cubed coming back to our
example why did the wood float and the
pin sink the wood floated on water
because the density of the wood is
lesser than the density of water
hence the upthrust of water on the wood
is greater than the weight of the void
hence it floated but the density of a
metal pin is more than two density of
water though it looks tiny there's more
mass per unit volume within it as
compared to water hence the upthrust of
water on the pin is less than the weight
of the pin so what can we conclude if
the density of an object is lesser than
the density of the liquid then it will
slow
and if the density of an object is more
than the density of the liquid there at
work think we understand the Archimedes
principle in the next video
[Music]